hello hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to let's play
bewilder house now I found this game I
don't know how I missed it but it was on
gamejolt and it looked really
interesting it was describing itself as
like some sort of a fun house that you
go through and I really don't know so
let's just get right into it
thank you they called me tall Oh Oh
better than all you guys calling me
short I'm not short I'm perfectly
average height just cuz I stand next to
what just cuz I stand next to wade all
the time and he's freakishly tall I
can't move what can I
oh my moved what I gotta move using the
arrow keys okay well this is weird WASD
does not move me it's actually the arrow
keys it movin it seems to be some sort
of minimum size but since I'm so
gigantic I guess this is gonna be OK for
me what's going on here pivoting theater
this is not the exit if you say so mr.
sign okay we got the age-old problem of
the mouse moving behind the screen so
I'm hoping I don't need to click
anything because this is going to be
pretty awful if I do you should take the
map Oh should I would you like really
okay I'll take your map that does not
look like a map what is going on here
this oh hello I'd like to colorful art
style it's definitely a lot more oh I
scooted what huh huh
take it what speak up huh get to the I
was gonna read that oh no this guy seems
to be I see balloons oh come on don't be
clicking you son of a [ __ ] see this is
exactly because I'm on my laptop am i my
like if I'm on the Louvre I'm on the
thingy my wrist will graze the trackpad
my laptop and it's just a giant son of a
[ __ ]
[Music]
pres du de Botton oh oh did I do good
did I do good okay drop off my map in
the bewilder house oh hello
that's really cool don't know what the
point is but it seems oddly sinto only
trust the map well I don't know about
that yeah whatever you okay I guess
that's where the whole bill will derp
thing comes into play
what Oh what oh I fell a long way how am
i okay all right then so there seems to
be some low the floor is hey hey I need
to go over there thank you very much
okay the floor is moving so I need to
kind of go along the way okay this is
wrong I need to find hey look it's a
certifiers okay to Santa oh hi oh yeah
followed me hey how's it going there
buddy pal mister you got something in
your eye my fist oh sorry that was not
my fist
that was uh no something else okay so
we're going over here hello I'm Josh
Thompson normal here oh no abnormal what
do you know
okay so I need to find the happy face
and then look at it in relation to this
is a dead end
oh crap wait a minute okay so I need to
find the happy face in whoa wait a
minute whoa whoa whoa whoa hey you're
[ __ ] with me ain't you you're [ __ ]
around a everything smooth oh okay this
is a dead oh okay this game is
officially messing with me and I don't
like it okay
uh-huh so uh about that well how am I
supposed to know where to go you dirty
rat aha
here is something different it's sort of
a thingy haha okay there we go let me in
hey what's all this then what screw you
too okay okay that's Oh whoo that was
too happy that was the sad face before
wait a minute you [ __ ] with me okay
so what are the room I need is straight
down from this the happy face if I go
this way ready here it's gotta be
through here I hear a pnina oh that's
why it's a banana my hero
let me just loop around in a circle and
then come back and then the door will
open yes yes no no loop around in a
circle come back and [ __ ] loop around in
a ding dong you better still be that
okay you're still the happy face okay
this is this is messing with my brain
now something's not right here where
this was not here before
aha oh really
okay I need to go one more down so
hopefully listen I'm not trusted II I'm
not going along uh-huh this is the rum
this is it M yeah oh did I do
I did it yeah I knew it I know I had it
I knew I had the right room cuz I don't
mark all right handsome right guys I'm
handsome right huh candies Y candies
what's going on I need to use the little
girl's room
I mean boys room sure my map get a new
map with them what is why is that what
what the hell is that that is a freaky
looking clown I've ever seen in my life
and I've seen quite a few freaky clowns
in my experience in playing games use
your eyes use this eye
hi there if I was in the oculus rift
what what oh I get it
ha ha um he follows when you don't look
what I didn't agree to this
hi how's it going buddy
that is a clown oh I see I need to look
at the eyes to open the door ok so I
need to look at you good god holy crap
what what the hell is wrong my oh my oh
my you won't escape next time you mean I
escaped this time Oh Lulu hi hi oh no oh
no oh no oh no indeed good sir
you will oh what the oh oh oh oh oh is
he still following me is he still
following me that's what I want to know
I got a feeling that he might still be
following me okay oh I'm going in the
clown door everybody I need to find
another location for them to map this
appears to be something in there hello
and I hear music playing this is little
Shirley very good for my hills
oh it's dark oh this is not the sort of
fun house that I appreciate here I do it
what oh there's a light it seems to be
some sort of light oh you son of a [ __ ]
I will Jack slap you you a ho oh no you
do not
oh no you do not oh crap there's
multiple doors hi hi how are you lovely
day to go [ __ ] off and go to hell how
about you oh my stop it stop that I'm
trying to be considerate of my neighbors
and you are being a dirty [ __ ] you
Piccadilly you know salable I hate you I
hate you I hate you I found a balloon I
need to find in relation okay so if this
is balloon if I go straight okay there's
a room to the left of the balloon is
there a room behind me okay those
there's no room behind me ergo there's
only a room to the left right and back
so I'm beginning to think this is well I
mean it could be any of them they're all
the same basically but if I go to a
corner is specifically if I go to the
left and look straight down and see one
I know where the room is you son of a
[ __ ] okay no it is not true it is not
down that way ergo doctor reasoning I've
determined that this isn't this doesn't
make any damn sense
hi I know you're moving I know you're
moving your son of a [ __ ] B okay so
this balloon is here I don't know what
it I don't I don't know what I'm doing I
don't know what I'm doing I do not know
what I'm oh what the what the hell are
you what oh you're that thing that ports
yeah stop it
okay there's another balloon over hi
friend
how are you are you doing okay there's a
balloon over damn it son of a pie I'm
not even shut up oh you're even uglier
in the light oh you're such a nice smile
how many times you brush your face okay
Ben - Ben Ben you bum okay ma'am Ben Oh
Megan oh you're getting a little too
close for comfort there buddy
little oh my god your head spins all the
way around ID I still don't know what
I'm doing here because I can't figure
out where oh god there's a doorway here
thank you I'm a nose is running I I
can't let go he's gonna kill me I don't
know I I don't know stop it stop stop I
I'm just playing little games with him
um he's doing backflips but where do I
go where to go what happened I don't
know don't want to know don't care need
to get out here haha doing a little hip
thrusts hey come on
alright fine I still doubt I where to go
what happens if i press am in the wrong
room okay this one's here fudge it I'm
gonna guess that it was the room that I
just came out of my nose is running
I'm disgusting I'm the YouTube is not
ready for me
oh my god my nose I don't know what
happened well actually I do know what
happened I did a hot pepper game review
oh I was wrong hello how'd you guys ah
damn it stop it okay this one's here how
about to the left of this one
no oh there's no wait a minute there
isn't one in a corner this is stupid
remember I'm just gonna keep going until
I get it November okay okay on that time
boo boo boo boo I'm going to every room
except the one I'm looking for
um damn it I was closed again I don't
think it's gonna teleport me to one
dammit ah screw you okay
damn it damn dabble it you five good
girls close Oh son of a [ __ ]
I'm god damn it I guess this one I'm
always just gonna guess to the left of
the bomb [ __ ] you
damn it where's another balloon just
give me a goddamn balloon stop with your
jerking I need to get through okay
here's a balloon see there's nothing to
the right so I'm gonna guess over here
oh god oh my god this puzzle this puzzle
is not fun yeah it's like the rules
aren't consistent I don't know what I'm
doing okay so if I go over here wait a
minute didn't I pour it in this room
already
ah I was on the other side okay so I
think I know where to go now see this
one is not the one yeah that's not the
one I knew it
okay so I need to find this one and oh
god damn stop porting me I don't know
where I am now Bonjour nutters I'm in
the exactly
I got me dammit all those those are
painted yes anyway that was really all
god dammit I'm here again oh the damn
sound oh I was right I think I spawned
in it I moved out of it son of a [ __ ]
okay goddamnit Cascadia Oh screw you
screw you hard who are you hard you
clown bastard oh [ __ ] you oh I don't
have time for your bull give me a
goddamn balloon we're ours I'm alone
okay there's a balloon I'm thinking I
got to get over here it's in this one
it's this one I know it is
[ __ ] you how about this one
nope god I can't
how many times do I need to do this I
can't be wrong
god damn it I can't be wrong this many
times guys I can't be wrong okay I guess
it's on the other side it's da [ __ ] ah
[Music]
it's on the other side of that wall but
how do I get to shut up hey [ __ ] you
yeah [ __ ] you how do I get over to there
oh hell I wasn't even close it was not
god damn it I keep getting over to the
thing I find a balloon me no no no ah
finally I knew it's [ __ ] you it's one of
those that it's on the other side of the
wall but there's like a wall there and I
can't I don't know how to get to there
that's why it's preventing me from doing
it cuz they don't know oh damn it I'm
trying to beat this game for you guys I
am trying
it is hard um you're a fast okay
this is not the one I know this isn't so
if I go this way and I turn a lift where
do you go where do you go where did he
go okay strange okay yeah there's a
balloon in here I know this way this is
a different balloon yeah this different
balloon god dammit this is just annoying
it's just annoying
oh [ __ ] you Oh
Oh next to it alright nurse to it okay I
have an idea I think I'm close I just
got to go the long way around this way
and then up this way to the end of this
hallway and when I get to the end of
this hallway that's where this is this
is it this is the one this is the one Oh
[Music]
God that took four ellic up whoa I done
fell down in a hole smash okay goddamn
that was ha ha oh how is your goddamn
dick ulis oh look it's toilet builder
hose oh man
my god hello again I don't know how long
this game is but uh it's pretty fun if
it wasn't for that one but maybe I'm
doing wow what the hell happened
oh we got some music going on now really
really hello they stopped
[Music]
[Music]
so nice okay I got to find the other
words the other eyeballs there it is
hello hello friend okay Oh can't look at
that thing okay it's gonna be
complicated but I can do this no problem
gotcha gosh you're locked in but no god
damn it I didn't wait was whoosh huh
okay I unlocked this platform that's a
cool feature I like that feature that is
a very cool feature okay so I just got
to keep my eye ball into you not look at
that one okay where's the where's the
other one who don't look gosh oh no god
dammit god dammit dammit dammit dammit
dammit dammit the rock the rock the rock
god dammit dabble it dabble it okay go
around now look at bumping no balls
balls balls balls oh look at both you're
both on my screen I know you are you
can't lie to me and say that you're not
you're a giant son of a [ __ ] if you say
anything otherwise I might stab you in
your goddamn face dr. dick bags horrible
land of illusions oh my god okay I got
both both ball both yes there we go
Kat damn it I picked up another freakin
map let screw your face Oh Bo dive super
rabies okay bring on the clown I'm going
right into his mouth oh I'm sure he's
getting some sort of sick pleasure out
of this one-way exit is on the third
floor Charlie knows like running what
what what happened well playing I don't
know
oh that's the end of it or that's the
end of the demo or the original thing
but that was really cool I mean I was
giving color commentary obviously so I
was like I was calling him a dick bag
but anyway it was my fault I wasn't
looking at it objectively
um the clown was scary for the first
part got real unscary real quick because
I mean he was silly I mean come on oh my
god I'm sorry my nose ready I just got
done with another hot pepper gaming
review if you haven't seen it already
you gotta check out I did a hot pepper
gaming review at Comic Con scuse me and
it was amazingly painful absolutely
horrifying but really fun to watch for
you guys so if you haven't seen it
already um I'll provide a link in the
description to see the next the first
one and expect the next one sometime in
the next week or sometime I don't know
he's got a bunch we went into his
apartment and we me and a bunch of other
youtubers in and other people it just
like did a whole bunch of recordings the
funniest thing ever I mean it was
totally off that I was crying crying my
eyes it was so funny for everyone else
watching and probably for you guys
watching when you see it but um I keep
an eye on that I'll be posting at the
channel I'll Facebook Twitter all that
sorta yeah so anyway hope you like this
this was actually a really cool game
really well made um it could use them
more music throughout the game you know
give it a more fun house feels kind of
silent and quiet for the most part um it
kind of added to the creepy atmosphere
but maybe like that carnival music
that's just a little off would have been
great for it I would have really added
to the atmosphere a whole bunch but
either way it was great I'm too stupid
to figure it out I'm too stupid omega-t
it out
so whatever eyes okay so anyway thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye